let's see if taking the transpose of a
matrix does anything to its determinant
so a good place to start is just with
the two-by-two scenario so let's do the
two-by-two scenario so if I start with
some matrix here let me just take its
determinant so a b c d and then let me
take its determinant so this is going to
be equal to a d minus bc now let me take
the transpose of this and then take its
determinant so that would be the
determinant of a see the columns turn
into the rows and then BD and the rows
turn into the columns now what is this
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to ad minus BC again the only
thing that happened is these two guys
got swapped and they multiplied time to
each other anyway so these two things
are equivalent so at least for the 2 by
2 case for the 2 by 2 case the
determinant of some matrix is equal to
the the determinant of the transpose of
that matrix now that's just the 2 by 2
case now I'm going to make an inductive
argument trying to show you an argument
by induction an argument by induction to
show that this works for all n by n for
all cases and the way you construct an
argument by induction is you assume you
assume that it's true for the N by n
case assume true for the N by n case so
let's assume so we assume that for if
for n by n that it let's say I have some
matrix I'm going to say I have some
matrix let me call it matrix B let's say
it's an N by n matrix we assume that the
determinant of any matrix B that's n by
n is equal to the determinant of B's
transpose that's where we start off with
our inductive argument and then we see
if given this if given that
is it also true is it true of n plus 1
by n plus 1 matrix because if we can if
we can say look given that it's true for
the N by n case it's going to be true
for the n plus 1 by n plus 1 case then
we're done because we know it's true for
the base case the 2 by 2 case which you
could say well that's your first n by n
so if it's true for the 2 by 2 case
it'll be 2 for the 3 by 3 case because
that's just one increment but then if
it's true for the 3 by 3 case it'll be
true for the 4 by 4 case but if it's
true for the 4 by 4 case it'll be true
for the 5 by 5 case and you just keep
going up like that so when you do a
proof by induction you prove a base case
and then you prove that if it's true for
n 4 or in this case an N by n
determinant if you can prove that given
it's true for an N by internment it's
going to be true for an n plus 1 by n
plus 1 determinant or an n plus 1 by n
plus 1 matrix then you have completed
your proof so let's see if this is the
case so let me construct let me
construct an n plus 1 by n plus 1 matrix
so let's say I have my matrix a my
favorite letter to use for matrices I
think the entire linear algebra is
favorite letter to use for matrices and
let's say it's an n plus 1 by n plus 1
matrix and just to simplify my notation
let's just say that M let's say that M
is equal to n plus 1 so we could call it
an M by M matrix and what is it going to
look like let's draw its entries right
here so it's going to have I'm going to
draw more than the normal amount of
entries a1 1 this is X first row a 1 2
all the way to a 1 M we have M columns
or actually n plus which is the same
thing as n plus 1 that's not n times 1
columns this is n plus 1 as well and
then we do our second row right here a 2
1 a 2 2 a 2 3 all the way to a to M then
you have your third row right here a 3 1
on a32 a33 all the way to a 3m and then
you go all the way down here at the end
the you have your amp throw which is you
could also say it's your n plus one
throw just a so it's your M throw first
column and then you have a sub M 2 and
then a sub M 3 all the way to a sub mm
fair enough now let me draw the
transpose of a so a transpose is also
going to be an N plus 1 by n plus 1
matrix which you could also write as an
M by M matrix I'm just going to take the
transpose of this C so the transpose of
that this row becomes a column so it
becomes a 1 1 then this entry right here
is a 1 2 it's this entry right there
then you have and you can go all the way
down all you could have all the way down
to a 1 M then this pink row becomes a
pink column here a 2 1 you have a I
wanted to do it in pink you have a 2 1 a
2 2 if you have an a 2 3 it goes all the
way down to a to M if your green row
right here it's your third one so it's
a31 a32 a33 all the way down to a 3 m
and then you can just skip a bunch of
rows in this case but it's columns in
this case so you just draw some dots and
you have a m one-a
m - I'm just going down this guy but
this row is now going to become which
was the last row is not going to become
the last column am 3 all the way down to
a mm and I have my transpose now let's
take the determinant of a let's take the
determinant of a now let me do it in
purple
so the determinant the determinant of my
matrix a we could just go to go down
this first row up here it's going to be
equal to its going to be equal to a11
times the determinant of its sub-matrix
so it's the determinant of this sub
matrix right here the determinant of
that sub matrix right there we could
call that the sub matrix a sub 1 1 we've
seen this notation before so it's the
determinant of a sub 1 1 and then it is
minus a 1/2 times the determinant times
the determinant of its sub-matrix so you
cross out that row in that column and so
that is going to be a sub 1/2 and you're
going to go all the way to and I don't
know the sign on that is we could call
it negative 1 to the to the 1 plus M
that'll give us the right sign for the
checkerboard pattern times the
determinant of the sub-matrix for this
guy so we call a 1 M where you cross out
that guy's row that guy's column and
you're just left with all of this stuff
over here
fair enough now let's look at the
determinant of a transpose the
determinant of a transpose we learned
earlier you don't have to go down the
first row or you don't have to even go
down a row you could go down a column so
let me be clear so for our determinant
of a we went down this row and our sub
matrices this was my first sub matrix my
second sub matrix you know what it looks
like you would cross out the second
column and that row and whatever is left
over would be the second sub matrix and
so on and so forth but for our
determinant of a transpose let's just go
down this first column and get the sub
matrices like that so this is going to
be equal to let's get our first term
right here a sub 1 1 times the
determinant of its sub-matrix so what's
the determinant of its sub-matrix it's
going to be it's going to be its sub
matrix you cross out its row and it's
column and you're going to be left with
you're going to be left with this thing
right here now an interesting question
is how does this thing that I've just
squared off this guy's sub matrix we're
- this guy's sub-matrix well if you look
at it carefully this row from 8 to 2 to
a 2m has now become a column from a 2 2
- a - M this row which is the next one
from a 3 2 to a 3m has now become a
column from a 3 2 to 8 3m you keep going
down this last row has now become this
column so this guy's sub matrix or the
determinant or the thing we're going to
take the determinant of right here is
equal to the transpose of this guy so
this is equal to a sub 1 1 a sub 1 1
transpose a sub 1 1 transpose and if you
go through it so and then we go - this
guy - a 1/2 times the determinant of his
sub matrix and if we cross out this
guy's row and that guy's column what is
that going to look like his sub matrix
is going to look like this it's going to
have that there and it's going to have
that right there now how does that
compare to a 1/2 so a 1/2 is if you
crossed out this and this and you're
left with all of this right here all of
this right here
so once again you see that this Row is
the same thing as this column that this
Row is the same thing as this column
that that Row is the same thing as that
column so once again this the sub matrix
we have to take the determinant of is
equal to the transpose of this thing
over here
so it's equal to a 1 2 transpose this
thing I could draw shaded in is equal to
the transpose of this thing is equal to
the transpose of that thing right there
so in general each of these sub matrices
when we go down this row is equal to the
transpose of each of these so you keep
going so then you're going to go all the
way to plus minus 1 we're going to go
all the way down to the minus 1 1 plus M
times the determinant of it's going to
be this guy it's going to be this guy
transpose you can even do it if you go
all the way to you cross that guy out
and that guy out you're left with
everything else on this on this matrix
and that's equal to the transpose of if
you cross this guy
out and that guy out this row turns into
that column that row turns into that
column I think you see the point I don't
want to beat a dead horse so that's
going to be equal to a sub 1 M transpose
now remember going into this inductive
proof or proof by induction
I assume that for remember this is an n
plus 1 by n plus 1 matrix but going into
it I assumed that for an N by n matrix
the determinant of B is equal to the
determinant of B transpose well these
guys right here these are n by n
matrices right this guy right here is an
n plus 1 by n plus 1 by n plus 1 same
thing for this guy right here but these
guys right here are n by n n by n so if
we assume for the N by n case that the
determinant of a matrix is equal to the
determinant of a transpose right this is
a determinant of matrix this is the
determinant of a trend of its transpose
these two things have to be equal so we
can then say that the determinant of a
transpose is equal to this term a sub 1
1 times this but this is equal to this
for the N by n case remember we're doing
the n plus 1 plus by n plus 1 case but
these sub matrices are one dimension
smaller in each direction has one less
row and one less column so these two
things are equal so instead of writing
this I can just write this so times the
determinant of a sub 1 1 and then you
keep going minus a sub 1 2 times the
determinant instead of writing this I
could write that because they're equal
determinant a sub 1 2 all the way to
plus minus 1 to the 1 plus M times the
determinant of this these two things are
equal that is equal to that that was our
assumption and this inductive proof a
sub 1 M and then you see that of course
this line this blue line here is
equivalent to this blue line there so we
get that the determinant of a which is
an n plus 1 by n plus 1 so this is the n
plus 1 by n plus 1 case
we get the determinant of a is equal to
the determinant of a transpose and we
got this assuming assuming that it is
true is let me write assuming that it's
true for n by n case and then we're done
we've now proved that this is true in
general because we proven the base case
we've proven it for the two by two case
and then we show that if it's true for
the N case it's true for the n plus one
case so if it's true for the two case
it's going to be true for the three by
three case it's true for the three by
three case it's true for the four by
four case so on and so forth but the
takeaway is pretty neat you can take the
transpose the determinant doesn't change